So, one of the most interesting projects I've worked on was actually a project
that arose out of personal interests. This was around the time that the Euro
2012, which is an international soccer competition was happening. And, so what
I did is I went on to the Euro website and I took a whole bunch of statistics
about the teams and the games. And I just took that information and I put it
into this piece of software. And it was instantaneously able to make these
predictions for me about who was going to win, what players were going to
perform the best. And that's not something you or I can do with the naked eye
very quickly or accurately. But, it's something that this computer could do
very well, very fast. And with only a year and a half of programming
background, it was information that I was able to extract.